the realm
do you know what the realm is
it's the thousand blades of aegon's
enemies
a story we agreed to tell each other
over
and over till we forget that it's a lie
what's up ladies and gentlemen welcome
back for another game of thrones and a
song of ice and fire video all right my
friends in this video i want to go over
some of the recently released
information from james andrew miller's
new book that reveals some very
interesting details about what happened
behind the scenes at hbo
now as you all know game of thrones had
one of the most divisive finales in
television history after ending the
series after only 8 seasons if any of
you have seen some of my other videos or
george rr martin's infamous red carpet
interview then you would know that he
has said game of thrones could have went
on for many many more seasons
as a matter of fact he said game of
thrones could have filmed for 13 or 14
more seasons if they would have directly
followed his books
why is it ending
i don't know ask dave and dan when they
come through
um we could have gone to
11 12 13 seasons but uh they
i guess they wanted a life
you wanted it to keep going
well it you know if you've read my
novels
you know there was enough material for
for more seasons they made certain cuts
um
but but that's fine we have five other
shows five prequels in development
that are based on other periods in the
history of westeros some of them
just a hundred years before game of
thrones some of them five thousand years
before game of thrones
and i'm working on other projects uh
nettie and i are working on a book
together this is uh neddy okorafor
she wrote an amazing book called who
fears death
that hbo has options so i'm an executive
producer on that and we're developing
that to be i hope than one of the next
big israel fantasy series now did you
know game of thrones would be ending
with this season or did they call you
and say hey let's have a chat
um
david and dan um
have been saying for yeah like five
years that seven seasons was all they
would go and we got them to go to eight
but uh
not any more than that so uh yeah i had
a custom a custom night there was a
period like five years ago where they
were saying
seven seasons and i was saying ten
seasons
and uh you know they won they're the
ones actually working on it so is there
a character that you would love to see a
spin off with
no i'm
committed to these prequels i mean i
think this story ends
when it ends and i know all the actors
as great as they are all the actors are
anxious to get on and play other roles
they don't want to spend their entire
lives playing one role and that's fine i
mean they're
it's great they're we had such an
amazing cast i mean not only the people
here tonight but some of the people
couldn't make it like
macy williams sophie turner
sabelle kakeli
um you know
mark addie who played robert in the
first thing great great great cast i was
honored to work with them
now the one thing that i did not know is
what actually happened behind the scenes
james andrew miller's new book reveals
that george rr martin actually begged
hbo to make more seasons of game of
thrones but the show runners david and
dan said no now according to george rr
martin's agent he said that george would
fly to new york to have lunch with one
of hbo's executives to beg him to do 10
seasons with the same number of episodes
because there was more than enough
material for it he also said it would be
a more satisfying and more entertaining
experience although miller and hbo's
executives would have loved to have more
seasons of the series the show's
showrunners david benioff and dan weiss
did not want to do this
dan and dave were exhausted and
rightfully so martin's agent describes
in miller's book they were done and they
wanted to move on so they cut it short
and then negotiations became how many
more seasons can we stretch this out
because of course hbo wanted more he
continued george loves dan and dave but
after season 5 he did start to worry
about the direction they were going in
because george obviously knows where the
story goes he started saying you're not
following my direction they were not
following a song of ice and fire now the
novels on which game of thrones is based
on a song of ice and fire is not yet
finished which may be why martin was
reluctant to have the series end after
only eight seasons
george has released the first five out
of seven novels and is continuing to
write the ones of winner which he has
been writing for over a decade he
describes in the book i wish it had run
for 10 years martin said in the book i
think that would have given us a little
more time in the later seasons to end it
however that might be just because i'm
trying to still end it myself i'm
working on the winds of winter even now
as i have been for the best part of a
decade the author continues and
hopefully i'm going to get to that
ending soon and then the fans can argue
about which ending they like better
now i don't exactly know how all of you
feel about this but i think it's
upsetting knowing that the creator of
this amazing universe had to beg hbo for
more seasons
no one and i mean no one knows this saga
better than george and he knew they
would need more seasons to ensure that
the fans were given a more satisfying
ending but then for dan and dave to not
follow through with this as a slap in
the face if you ask me i guess i will
never understand why hbo did not hand
over the reins to someone else who was
willing to end it the way that they
wanted i think dan of dave should have
honored george rr martin's wishes by
handing it over themselves i also find
it a little hard to believe that george
rr martin still has love for dan and
dave after how everything ended at least
not the same love that he had for them
when they were heading into the series
from day one not only did george stop
working on the show but he even stopped
watching it now he said he stopped
watching it because he was writing the
wins of winner but that isn't exactly
what happened either now if you go back
and look at his social media you can see
that he would discuss other shows even
while game of thrones was on the air
making it very clear at least for me
that he had some sort of falling out
with david and dan i think something
happened behind the scenes that
fractured their relationship and we can
all assume that it was most likely over
creative differences but at the end of
the day what do i know
i wasn't there and this is only my
perspective as an outsider i just hope
that one day we will find out what
actually happened because i don't think
we have been given the full story yet so
long as hbo is still handing george
millions of dollars he will never fully
speak his mind on the situation but
maybe someone else who was working with
him on the show will eventually
now there is some more very interesting
information that was also revealed in
this book that i will be discussing in
my next video hopefully i will see all
of you here for that one as well as
always let me know what all of you think
about this new information what do you
think hbo should have done with game of
thrones before it ended should they have
let dan and dave end it early like they
did or should they have found someone
else to end the show the way that george
wanted leave your thoughts down below i
want to thank everyone for watching i
will see you again very soon
bye
[Music]
[Music]
you